[Music]
you know which one of my biggest
challenges when I communicate with
somebody like you who thinks they're way
way far away from winning big if you are
so much closer to winning than you think
you are but I'm going to explain it to
you in a way today that maybe it'll make
sense to you let me tell you what I'm
talking about
so if success and failure were human
beings who would they be
in real life let me tell you what
failure would be failure would be the
bully the bully who talks so much game
when they fight I would beat the crap
out of you again you know I'm gonna kick
your ass I'm going to do it and a bully
is convincing that's why they're so good
at it
they're not gone and so most people back
down from a bully and 99% of time we
back down from a bully but all their
other bully the way you defy your bully
is to face a bully and you realize man
I'm not that far away I'm not a failure
I'm just being bullied by the spirit of
failure now let me explain to successful
B this is who the spirit of success
would be you know when you have this one
girl who is so beautiful you know what
I'm talking about utility two Scrolls
out of my league
that girl's convinced you she's out of
your league it's her job to convince you
she's out of your league
she's supposed to do that and you look
at it she gives you no son she doesn't
do one of these things she doesn't get
nervous and have a nervous twitch
nothing nothing but she's interested
what you think you're so far from her
being interested in you while you're
this close this close so this is why the
people who win big in life at one point
had to face the balloon and at one point
have to seduce to success and say you
belong to me and you're going to like
being with me and you get a lot of being
with me and we're gonna be together one
day but I'm patient because I'm a lot
closer than you think I am and if you
can pull that off I guarantee you're
going to wake up on this you know my
gosh failure doesn't scare me at all
and I seduced success to marrying me
that's a pretty good marriage to have in
life if you can seduce success
[Music]
you